this is a production of Cornell
University hey so hi I'm Liz anything
Susan introduce my my project pretty
well I've just been looking at
temperature impacts and irrigated maize
and I'll start out by giving you a
little background so mazes the top
cereal crop produced on a weight basis
in the world and it's of critical
importance to food security and also to
energy budgets and because of that
there's a lot of interest in if these
cropping systems are going to remain as
productive as they are today with a
changing climate there's a lot of local
variability and uncertainty in climate
projections but there's consensus that
air temperatures are going to increase
in the coming century and in the past
decade there's been a number of studies
that have developed econometrics models
that are trying to look at these air
temperature impacts on yields whether we
can make projections about maize
cropping system yields based on air
temperature alone and some of these some
of these studies have come up with some
pretty startling results that first one
by Schlenker and Roberts showed that
based on an on your relationship with
increasing air temperature in maize
yields we could see declines amaze yells
up to eighty-two percent in the next
century because of climate change a low
bail at all in 2009 showed that these
yields have already dropped by three
point eight percent since 2009 after
they adjusted for a yield trend in their
data and then Arielle Ortiz Barbara in a
recent work that was challenging the the
validity of using a single climate
metric to make these projections warned
that the growing consensus is that
climate change impacts will largely be
driven by exposure to heat we also see
some evidence that suggests that this is
not the whole story um so as you know
amis is grown in Argentina Ecuador
Ontario there's a lot of different
temperature regimes where Mays is being
grown and what constitutes a heat stress
threshold in one place doesn't
necessarily mean it's a a heat stress
threshold in another place
similarly we've seen that what
constitutes a stressful temperature can
change in one location from season to
season and you know so in some ways the
mazes response to heat represents an
acclimation process is modified by prior
temperature regime similar you some
other studies have come out that have
shown that how we manage our maze
cropping systems interacts with the
temperature response as well and there's
been evidence presented that management
can help to a buffer some of these
negative impacts from air temperature
alone so that we have the ability to
adapt our systems to the temperature and
I'm probably most importantly down here
a recent work by by Suzumiya and Steven
Shaw over at SUNY ESF showed that if
you're looking at irrigated maize
cropping systems this apparent response
to temperature just just about
disappears which suggests that on
previous models might have been
complaining heat and water stress which
are of course often related in these
systems so what we were interested in
doing is seeing if this econometrics
approach can be used to get at the
mechanism of heat stress in these
cropping systems and our approach to
doing this was to break the maze growing
season down a min to gross development
periods which is not at all unusual the
idea here is that heat stress occurring
at different points in these growth and
development is going to have a very
specific very different mechanisms that
are contributing to that heat stress
response that we're seeing in yields and
that different adaptation mechanisms
would be needed to be developed
depending on what that heat stress
mechanism was we also looked at more
than just temperature with a little bit
of nuance because depending on how you
how you break it down on multiple
climate variables can come into play and
helping you to determine exactly what
that heat stress mechanism is another
thing that we did and I'm going to go a
little bit more into detail about this
later is we modeled the duration of our
growth development phases using thermal
time instead of using set intervals for
them you know the reason here is we're
looking at temperature stress we're
looking at when the temperature stress
is happening in growth development if
those high temperatures are changing the
duration of the gross development
periods
we'd want to be able to capture that as
an artifact also increased rates of
physiological development have been
suggested as a heat stress mechanism in
these so our objectives once again were
to see if we could get at amaze yield
response to high temperature if we were
adjusting for these other confounding
factors such as management or more
importantly moisture stress we wanted to
see if we could do a mechanistic
analysis of this heat stress by looking
at the timing of heat stress during crop
development and we wanted to see if we
could quantify the potential adaptation
for management and genetics so we were
able to do this using like an enough in
the kind of metric model because we had
a really amazing Bank of yield data to
work with National Corn Growers
Association is one of the two largest
maize advocacy organizations in the US
and winners of the National corn yield
contest I've consistently set world
records for maize yields so we had we
got historical yield data from the
National Corn Growers Association we got
all contest entries and we kind of
secured a data set where management has
been optimized you know the goal of
these growers is to get to that that
yield potential the place where we only
did was holding their yields back our
climate and the potential of the
cultivar we only looked at irrigated
classes once again we wanted to control
for the soil moisture stress we looked
at the states of kansas missouri and
nebraska for two reasons we had a really
high density of irrigated yields in
these states and also especially with
Kansas and Missouri we're getting some
of the highest temperatures that we're
going to get in the Corn Belt we looked
for the years 2005 to 2012 once again
for a few reasons we had significant
interannual variability in yields also
in climate conditions including 2012
which was a very hot year and we didn't
have any significant yield trend that
needed to be adjusted for for our
climate data we used hourly climate data
from the Missouri meza net and the High
Plains Regional Climate Center
we had access to almost 70 weather
stations in our study area all the data
had been quality controlled in gap
filled and we match that climate data to
our yield values based on proximity and
also similar GDD zone so once again
we're trying to make sure we're getting
as close to accurate temperature
conditions as we could hear from there
like I had mentioned before one thing
one thing that I forgot to mention that
was pretty important with the yield
contest data just going to go back we
have access to we have access to the
planting date and the cultivar as well
as a whole bunch of other management
parameters so that the management
parameters are important because one of
our research questions were you know do
we have can we quantify these
adaptations potential to any temperature
impacts through management the second
thing that's important here is if we
have the planting date and the cultivar
we can take that planting date to start
our growing season we can use cultivar
specified GDD to maturity and to silking
to model with pretty fine resolution
what our growth development periods
we're using thermal time so going back
to our climate variables we calculated
temperature stress in a few ways that
had been that we found on the literature
we had hourly data so we were able to
calculate can you live degree hours over
different temperature thresholds we
looked at quite a few of them but i'm
going to talk here about 30 degrees and
34 degrees so this is the amount of time
that the crop spent in a temperature
stress condition we also have with those
variables a zero stress situation where
there was where we had no temperatures
above that that's threshold we use ktd
so katie d stands for killing degree
days it's often called extreme degree
days to in the literature this is the
same thing as a normal growing degree
day calculation except for you're
setting your base temperature at what
you would consider your temperature
stress threshold and there's no upper
limit so that's cumulative degree days
where daily p max was over 29 degrees C
because that once again the value that's
most often being used in the literature
we also looked at average night
temperature which is pretty
self-explanatory and cumulative solar
radiation
and then for for each yield value we
calculated this over the growing season
and also during growth development
periods once again all of those
durations were modeled using thermal
time because we wanted to be able to
quantify I guess the magnitude of yield
response from climate impacts relative
to other variables that we had access to
in this data set we used a mixed effects
model for fixed effects we use planting
rate plate to date cultivar ddd maturity
and um previous crop those were in the
model because they were the most
significant we had random effects for
cultivar so that would be genetic
variation that's not due to the maturity
class location once again pretty
self-explanatory if there's um yeah if
there's any location-based trends in our
yields form ID nested and location that
lets us look at the difference between
farm a and farm be that are in close
proximity to each other so that would be
management level differences that we
can't get out with our data oils and
then we also looked at your planting
because we're specifically interested in
seeing if we can explain any of the
intra annual yield variability
variability that we know is in our data
using climate variables after we built
this base model I climate variables were
tested as fixed effects and then once
again we could get the relative
magnitude of yield response out of that
so first most of the most of the most of
the studies that were following up on
looked at the accumulation of heat
stress over the entire growing season
when we did that with our irrigated
yields we saw that none of our daytime
temperature stress indices were
significantly related to yield which was
a little bit of a surprising result
radiation as you'd expect in irrigated
maize under optimum management was
significant related to yield an average
night temperature was also significantly
related to yields um when you look at
the yield responses on a standardized
scale so change in standard deviations
of predictor variable / change and
standard deviations and yield they're
about equal to magnitude and inverse of
each other so we see that night
temperature has an impact
can we get at the mechanism for you'll
decline due to high night temperatures
so going back before we did model the
duration of our growing season using
thermal time we were trying to get at a
potential heat stress mechanism which is
accelerated rates of phenological
development by doing it that way there's
two kind of conflicting schools of
thought about why night temperatures
with impact yield one is that increased
night temperatures leads to night
respiration and the other is that
increased night temperatures increase
development rate so you would just like
I spoke about end up with less
intercepted radiation per unit thermal
times over the life of your plant
because we modeled our growth periods
using thermal time and we calculated our
irradiation variable by those five by
that model we kind of already cap
captured that we pen or we've captured
the accelerated seen a logical
development with radiation as the
variable that would define us so what
we're looking for here is an impact of
night temperature independent of
radiation and we didn't see one so as
far as we can tell with our data set in
our method of analysis we're not seeing
an impact of I guess some of night
respiration but our our data seems to
support the fact that the impact of
night temperatures is increased rates of
development so we'll we'll go from there
once again radiation was the most yield
limiting climate variable this just kind
of illustrates that point with this data
the graft on the Left shows our yields
in blue by year and then our
distribution of radiation is shown in
pink also by year and as you can see
they kind of they track each other
somewhat somewhat nicely there the graph
on the right is the same thing yields in
blue but the distribution of our high
temperatures are illustrated in pink and
you see like in 2009 low temperatures
high yields 2012 where we actually had
our highest yields in the corn and in
the yield cantos data set was actually
also the hottest year in our record so
we know that radiation is has the most
explanatory power of any of our climate
variables we also know that it's
correlated with high temperatures the
next question is could the positive
yield response from radiation beam now
getting any impact of high temperatures
when we moved into our growth
development phase analysis we decided to
look at radiation and high temperature
at the same time in the model we also
picked et 34 because when we were
modeling our thermal time we had a cut
off on our GDD of 34 degrees and so
hopefully this would be getting at
temperatures that we haven't already
accounted for by increasing the rates of
development there when you look when you
do account for radiation the model d
time temperature does become significant
but it does so in kind of an odd way
generally during early growth right here
you see that TT 34 and grain fill teeth
or early growth and Greenville high
temperatures have a slight negative
association with yields but these came
into the model as being significant with
a crossed effect so pretty much we saw
that early growth radiation modifies
yield response to high temperatures that
are happening during grain fill and I
just saw that Ron early growth exposure
to stressful temperatures gives us a
positive response to those same
stressful temperatures that they happen
again during grain film so if you didn't
your prop wasn't exposed to any high
temperatures in the spring a big heat
wave comes around during grain fill
you'll see a yield decline as long as
you've had consistently high
temperatures you actually get the
opposite effect it seems to be
beneficial for yields so a modification
there maybe of what's constituting a
stressful temperature the other thing
that you see is that radiation remains
significant we see how positive estimate
here so this these regression estimates
such system the changes standard
deviations of yield that would happen
with one of those predictor variables
but you also see that high greenfield TT
34 during high well 52-34 during grain
fill negatively modifies the positive
yield response you get from increasing
radiation even though we have
significant climate effects these
climate effects are only explaining a
very very small amount of the total
yield variants that we had in our data
so this right here just yield variance
explained by model affect all of our
random effects are in purple our fixed
effects are in green and radiation and
TT 34 so all of us
picking climate affects land about here
they only explain just under six percent
of the total variance in the data set to
contrast that like genetics which you
can find in this pool right here other
genetics and also in cultivar GDD to
maturity so maturity class and then
everything that's left over that
explains yields besides maturity class
explained more yield variance than our
climate variables did planting rate and
planting date explained more yield
variance than our climate variables in
putting these climate variables into the
model only explained about fifteen
percent of our inter annual yield
anomaly so we still have a whole lot of
inter annual variance in our year in our
yields and then what I want to point out
right here is the farm level variance so
the difference between farm a and farm
be that our neighbors to each other is a
pretty significant pool of our of our
variance here and then the residual
error this is just like the traditional
Arab term that you'd see in any linear
model was just over thirty percent of
the total variance and the in the data
set so it's also noisy data so you'll
notice when I was looking at the
regression coefficients before I didn't
point out that there was a significant
temperature impact during silking which
is when at least I was expecting to see
the strongest temperature impact and
overall when you look at the entire the
entire population of cultivars that's
true there was no significant impact of
high temperatures during smoking on
yields we broke our data set down to
include only cultivars that had been
represented by more than 10 years yield
variables and then we test them to see
if there was any significant crossed
effects between those cultivars and the
temperature stress synthesis so do any
cultivars have a unique relationship
with temperatures dress now we saw that
yes they do not very many of them but
there was a handful of cultivars that
did appear to be sensitive to high
temperatures during the Sun sort of
period as we defined it but that with
these cultivars that were sensitive we
saw the most variability and cultivar
performance only under the no stress
condition so the cultivars that were
significantly impacted by temperatures
during the sensitive period they
performed about as well as everyone
Thunder really stressful conditions but
they were the ones that were over
yielding the rest of the pack under non
stress conditions creating this model
that looks at cultivar as a fixed effect
it does not significantly improve our
understanding of the temperature impacts
over our model that has it as a fixed
effect based on our model selection
process so I just note that this is just
more anecdotal and it suggests that
maybe if there are still temperature
sensitive cultivars out there that could
be taken into account you know as part
of adaptation mechanisms there then the
last thing that we wanted to see was by
altering our management practices can we
adapt to our temperature stress and
disses as we saw them even though they
were slight and as far as we can tell
the answer is yes so over here on the
left this is the on your x-axis here you
have early growth 22 34 on the y-axis
here you have brain fealty to 34 and
then the z axis is yield response and
this is under average management so just
the mean of everything in our data sets
average cultivar to maturity I'm dddd
maturity average planting date average
planting rate if you have no stress in
early growth and then you increase your
stress level during grain fill your
yields decline high stress during early
growth high stress during Grange Hill
you get a yieldboost go figure um so and
then same thing over here except for now
we've created a scenario that we called
optimal management so now we have just
slightly increased our planting dates
we've slightly decreased our planting
dates we've chosen a higher performing
cultivar that performed across a wide
range of climate conditions it was 33
why 75 it was on that other graph it was
also a longer season cultivar and we see
that pretty similarly no matter what you
just want to have high temperatures
early in the spring which makes us
because we're talking about an earlier
planting date here but the real thing
that I wanted to point out here is that
even slightly optimizing from within the
range of current cultural practices
you're on a totally different scale then
you see with your worst case scenario
you know worst-case scenario but
slightly optimal management doesn't even
overlap with best case scenario average
management so you know this sort of
tells us that within the range of
temperature impacts that we're currently
seeing and we did see some really high
temperatures in this data set you know
maybe the sky isn't falling you know
alright so the conclusions there's not
much evidence of temperature sensitivity
and irrigated maze-like temperature was
associated with decreased radiation and
also with decrease yields radiation is
the most yield limiting climate variable
that we saw on these systems high
temperature reduces the impact from
increased radiation during grain fill so
we're not getting as much of that
yieldboost for more radiation if it's
hot but we also see that with our
observed temperature impacts we have
evidence of acclimation so prior
temperature regime experienced by the
crap is going to impact whatever its
response is to temperatures later on
climate impacts explain very little
yield variance and can be compensated
for by slightly optimizing management
and so you know that just kind of brings
me to my final point controlling for
soil moisture if you're going to be
doing this type of econometrics and
Alice's to make yield projections and a
change in climate seems like it could be
of some importance go I just want to
thank everybody on my my committee and
also yeah and also Peter for for all
your help I also want to thank I wish
she was here I'm Erica Murdoch who was
my consultant / that the Cornell
statistical consulting unit she's great
if anybody hasn't had a chance to meet
her and then all the rest yes thank you
very much
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu